tens of thousands of students are suing
their universities because they say they
missed out on high quality education
during the pandemic and Strikes here's
everything you need to know I want to
feel like
you know what I paid for the degree
was was worth it
more than a hundred thousand people have
signed up to this no win no fee dispute
and up to 100 universities could be
involved
This legal action focuses on students
who are enrolled during the pandemic and
also those who are impacted by strikes
up until last year I had a whole year
where I couldn't access any of the
facilities of the University
I was getting the teaching I could go on
placement but I wasn't really getting
any support with my
like doing the academic work there are a
lot of people who are just like me
probably who are sat in libraries
studying on their own or who are not
knowing about Societies or things that
are going on around University kind of
adjusted and just accepted that that's
my University experience and not
necessarily the one I was promised
King's College London and UCL say their
staff worked hard to deliver high
quality education and that they
recognize the disruption of the pandemic
on students
[Music]
they want compensation and are asking
for up to five thousand pounds but it
could be more for foreign students or
those who are doing postgraduates as
they pay higher fees the students were
promised a service by the universities
and they were delivered a lesser service
so we're arguing for them to be paid
back the difference between what they
were promised and what they and and what
was delivered
well they say they still delivered
learning albeit online and of course
they still had costs such as paying
staff they want students to go through
their internal complaints procedure or
to go through the higher education
ombudsman UCL are applying to stay the
case
indefinitely so that the students get
shunted to its internal complaints
procedures we say that that's a nonsense
as much as anything
UCL so far has denied all liability and
refused to pay our clients any
conversation whatsoever so why would
going through its own internal complaint
procedure lead to a different result if
it size that UCL students can take their
case to court it will set a precedent
for all the other universities but
lawyers for the students argue it will
end up in the courts regardless it's
just a question of how long the process
will be